Wassup Droogie? This week gettin’ a taste
of the ol ultra-violent with A Clockwork Orange
by Anthony Burgess.
England sho as hell seen better days. Cuz
up in this crooked-ass future, the government
got errybody by the nuts and young thugz rule
the streets doin violent deeds on the reg.
And there ain’t no gang rollin rougher than
Alex and his droogies Dim, Georgie, and Pete.
One night after sippin some of that crunk-stuff
at the Korova Milk Bar, Alex and his boys
hit the streets to get their fix of sweet
violence. After whoopin up some strangers,
lootin’ a store and boosting a car, Alex
and da crew swang through the boonies when
they stop a cottage, mask up, bust in, BRUTALIZE
da husband and rape his woman while he WATCH.
Damn, B. This is some f***** up sh*t right
hurr.
Later, dem Droogies start flexin like they
be questioning Alex’s authority. But when
Alex whips out his shank, he puts dem bitches
back in their place. Cold blooded.
That night they decide to step up their game
by robbin some rich old hag’s crib. Alex
sneak in and knock dat bitch out, but not
before the 5-0 be closin’ in.
Just as Alex bout to bail, Dim pops Alex in
his grill, leaving him to get GOT by the fuzz.
Now 15-yr old Alex got his ass tossed in the
clink. Damn.
After Alex smacks up one his cellmates real
good, he gets picked to be a lab rat for some
shit called The Ludovico Technique. Basically,
a bunch of government scientists pump his
ass with drugs, make him watch videos of real messed up sh*t, and condition him to get sick
as a dog whenever he think of something violent
or sexual. Thing is, these videos sometimes
bumpin classical music, which be one of the
only things that mean a damn thing to him.
Now he can’t listen to his jam without losin
his yarbles. Since he “rehabilitated,”
Alex gets released to the outside.
While Alex lurkin round da streets, he keeps
gettin his ass kicked by people who recognize
him from his gang-bangin days. Just when sh*t’s gettin rough, the law breaks up the scuffle.
But turns out, one of these badge-wavin crackas
is DIM. Da hell?!
After gettin straight F***** up by some back then hustlaz, Alex stumbles to a cottage beggin
fo help. Turns out, Alex now chillin with
the same brutha whose ass he beat and whose
wife he raped. Luckily, he don’t recognize
Alex at first. Instead, he just wanna use
Alex as a poster boy for his posse of anti-government
blowhards. But just like the government, they
just gonna put the hurt on Alex for they own
ends. So they lock him up in a room, start
bangin some classical music, and Alex try
to snuff it.
But since dat was a little bitch fall, Alex
ends up aight. Actually he better than aight.
He been cured of the Ludovico Technique. After
a while, Alex gets to thinkin, realize how
empty his life be, and decide to stop thuggin
ultra violent, and make himself a one lady
man. Man this ending sucks. GO WATCH THE MOVIE!
Now yo bitch-ass might be thinkin: Da hell
this got to do with oranges? Well peep this,
sucka- tha book’s title spittin game bout
tryna take something organic, like an orange,
and tryna make it work like a machine- which
is exactly what errybody tryin to do to Alex,
not just the scientists. And if Alex cayn’t
choose between good and evil, then he ain’t
a human being- he’s just a clockwork orange.
Matter of fact, Alex’s name got a built
in “f*** you” to all those people tellin
him how he gotta roll. See, da name Alexander mean “defender of man.” And in Alex’s
case, he’s fighting for humanity’s right
to choose even if they choosin to do some
twisted things.
Look, even though the state tryin to do some
good by usin the jacked up Ludovico Technique,
they ain’t just riddin the world of evil.
They also killin the good. Like one of dem
goverment puppets say-
“Delimitation is always difficult. The world
is one, life is one. The sweetest and most
heavenly of activities partake in some measure of violence – the act of love, for instance;
music, for instance.”
See problem is cultures always thinkin in
black and white. Something’s either good
or its evil. But on the real, it’s never
that simple. Nothing’s ever completely good
or completely evil.
But no matter how many damn times some ballin’ artist or philosopher spit dat truth, we just
can’t seem to understand it. Humanity gonna think they got errything all figured out,
only to bone up and do it over and over again. Like clockwork, playa.
So start yo re-education by hittin dat subscribe button, padna. Viddy- well my literary OGs.